[Music]
william is with us in greenville south
carolina hi william how are you
i'm doing great dave and ken it's an
honor to speak to you congratulations on
what you're doing for america well thank
you sir how can we help today yes
well i've i first heard you a long long
time ago when i lived in nashville
working at applebee's and um
anyway i've realized that i didn't have
the right size shovel and so i've worked
my whole life until i have the right
size shovel i believe
but um in my wife and i've been
debt-free but i've but i'm
kind of in steps four five and six i've
already well i've paid for my children's
college
but i've arrived at the age of 53
without
saving 15 and without paying off my
house
and i'm just wondering you know to work
from 53 to 63 i don't think 50 15 will
get me there
should i should i break the money that
i'm able to save now 50 50 and do that
or should i focus more on
a mute i've just never trusted the stock
market but i've you know you preach it
every day and i'm just wondering
at 53 what would you do
well we don't have to do anything in
baby step five four is fifteen percent
of your income going into retirement and
everything else going towards the house
how much do you owe on your home
uh about five hundred thousand okay and
what's your household income
about this between fluctuates because i
owned i had i actually had to start the
company to get my shovel right but it's
it's between 800 and
850 900 depending on just depends on the
year
but it hasn't always been that way i got
to catch my breath here a little second
did you just say 800 000 a year
yes sir okay
and you don't think 15 is going to get
you there
no okay well i mean well let's do it
let's do it let's do a little math okay
uh okay year one
you live on three hundred thousand
dollars and you pay off your home
well wait a minute
let's pay taxes on that eight to nine so
let's call it five
is that fair
okay it takes two years
and you live on 250.
why
okay i'm not why i know i'm just giving
you a hard time 55 years old your house
is paid for and you make 8.50 and you
own the company
so what is the destiny of this company
upon retirement
um
it will be sold
it's a garbage company and what we do
is um
it's really worth asset value at the end
it's there's really not a big pot of
gold the gold comes as you work it
you can't sell it while it's being
worked for this tremendous cash flow
um
no it's it's it's not it's not that type
of company i mean i know what you're
talking about you hear these
big big companies come in and swoop in
and pay you know because most companies
that you make 800 000 of your profit on
you could sell the company
well
i just i've just i just know that people
that do what i do they sell i mean i
read the trade rags they sell their
companies for
asset value at the end
so your trucks i'm really not looking
not looking for a big lick yeah trucks
and dumpsters and stuff yes yeah all
right well done
very well done well thank you love it
proud of you
um
in the old book the millionaire next
door
and uh there's a few other pieces of
literature out in the millionaire stuff
that uh one of the um
most likely to become very wealthy by
the way is your trade
it's a it's a dirty little secret no pun
intended so um
but uh
but so okay here we did so we were 55
years old you make 800 a year you don't
have a payment in the world and so how
much are we going to bank a year after
of your 500 after taxes how much you're
going to put in mutual funds
um
from that point from that point forward
because you're at baby step seven two
years from now
right so so you're saying
pay your house off and then
save three or four hundred thousand
dollars a year mutual fund so two or
three yeah yeah i'm saying it doesn't
matter
if you flip it and do it the other way
you're still gonna get there because
you're right you don't have a shovel you
have a truck in fact you have a whole
fleet of trucks yeah you're just
counting that's amazing so your income
is your answer um yeah just get but just
lay out a very intentional plan to say
i'm going to invest this much i'm gonna
pay this house off boom just like that
wow yeah unbelievable not to mention
what he could save from his company buy
some other assets that make money
unbelievable